[Music]
in some ways we've been making amazing
progress for 40 years in my opinion in
the mathematics of field theory which is
the underlying geometric structure that
undergirds both particle theory and
general relativity so this has been an
incredibly exciting time because this
dictionary has opened up which ports all
of the best insights from physics into
differential geometry and from
differential geometry back into physics
so you'd be hard-pressed to say that
nothing is happening the problem is is
that we really wanted to quantize the
geometry of general relativity
but in fact what we ended up doing was
geometry seing the quantum and so it's
been a bit of a disappointment for
theoretical physicists who hoped that
they would be living through a Golden
Age of theoretical physics rather than
the mathematics of theoretical physics
so the field of particle theory has in
some ways seemed to be advancing in
terms of its mathematical underpinnings
but the elaborations on the standard
model which is our specific
understanding of the world in which we
live has been all but stalled from the
theory side since around 1973 1974 so
it's a bit of a paradoxical situation
and I think that in part we've we've
never really been here before there was
a period between about 1928 till the
late 40s when theoretical physics had
found quantum electrodynamics the theory
of electrons and photons where most of
the calculations we wanted to do gave
infinite answers the underlying theory
seems sound we just didn't know how to
get real contact with experiment and it
took a long time for us to realize that
we had a technical problem rather than a
need for an absolutely fundamental
revolution of the kind that brought us
general relativity and quantum theory
so I think that we're we're a bit stuck
and we don't really know how long this
very strange period is going to go on
for and this period has been dominated
by these sort of quixotic hopes that one
of a number of theories whether it be
supersymmetry Theory grand unified
theory Technicolor or even
noncommutative geometry might be our way
out but the problem is is that all of
these highly speculative theories have
remained in limbo and many of them have
gotten rolled in to this very strange
complex of ideas that we call either
string theory or m-theory or some
variant thereof and it is a question as
to whether this is more of a physics
inspired theory or whether it's really a
an economic and sociological phenomenon
which is that you have a generation that
physicists in the baby-boom who seem to
be absolutely astounding geometers but
appear to be wanting in terms of their
ability to make contact with the natural
world by the standards of previous
generations and naturally that's going
to elicit some very strong feelings
because the idea that we would have had
perhaps two generations let's say in 40
years of physicists who can't make
contact with experimental reality with
their theories is completely
unprecedented in the modern era this is
this is very interesting and rather
disturbing so I was quite inspired by a
talk or two that I've seen of the
distinguished physicist Nima or Connie
Hamed where in essence he points out
that the three main equations that give
us all of theoretical physics the Dirac
equation from matter and then the force
equations the yang-mills equation and
the Einstein field equations are all in
some sense provably the best possible
equations in their category of equations
and so what happened was we had a
question
is there any way to go about finding
even better equations and we can
essentially prove that these equations
cannot be beaten in any simple way so
the possible elaborations I would say
are now obvious and we've tried all of
them and none of them have seemed to
yield to anything that clearly advances
our picture beyond where we are now so
the question is do we need a radical
rethinking is there something wrong with
the fundamentals is Einstein in fact
wrong to slip in space-time at the
ground floor of theoretical physics
which is shared by both quantum field
theory and general relativity or are we
simply in that situation where you think
you've searched your apartment
everywhere for your missing spectacles
or keys but in fact it was hiding in
plain sight the whole time you just
didn't think to look in the right place
and I would say that the jury's really
out and the problem is that this is in
some sense and I say this not as an
insider in physics but really as an
outsider since I wasn't trained in that
subject per se but this is the world's
most accomplished intellectual community
whether you find them easy to deal with
or sometimes rather unpleasant as I
occasionally do there is no question in
my mind that no other group has ever
achieved anything like the theoretical
physics community but the question is
why are they stumped and if they do need
help where can it come from it doesn't
seem that any of the chemists or the
biologists would have enough to
contribute even though physics has
contributed to both of those fields and
so the real hope is is that it's either
going to come from the theoretical
physicist themselves from mathematicians
who struggle to make any kind of contact
because the pedagogy in physics is quite
forbidding and I would say it's not not
quite as good as the pedagogy and
mathematics generally speaking or is it
going to come from some completely
strange source maybe somebody who is the
self teacher off the grid that we've
never heard of but we've heard from all
of the the leaving lights and I would
have to say that almost no one
from the traditional community really
has any kind of a great idea as to how
to make the next the next progress well
I think that if you think about
Einstein's vision abstractly properly he
in all probability I think he'll be
proved right in the end and the in the
abstract but the key question is did he
get some of the particulars wrong he has
a beautiful quote where he says that his
equation can be viewed as a mansion with
two wings one of which is made from fine
marble and the other is made from cheap
wood being the two signs of the equality
now most people have looked at the cheap
wood and said well our theory of matter
and the stress energy tensor as it's
known technically is probably what needs
to be upgraded so that the equation is
pure marble on both sides there's a
rather more disturbing possibility which
is that the marble is in fact a
premature codification of the geometry
and that in fact it has it is not
impossible that we have been so beguiled
by the beauty and elegance of the marble
side of Einstein's equation that we
haven't put nearly the time or the
energy into figuring out whether that's
where the problem is but the problem for
us if we do go down that route is is
that Einstein's theory is so locked in
at this point through path dependence
we've built everything upon his insights
that it's not really clear how you could
make a modification to the foundations
of physics without having the whole
thing collapse around you and so even if
you have an idea that you're going to do
something very heterodox which is to
question the bedrock or the marble of
the geometry the question is can you
even get to it given the incredible
skyscraper that has been built on his
solid geometric foundations so this is
in some sense the route that I've gone
down which is to try to think about
novel approaches if you are going to
break with the community it's very
difficult to keep up with that level of
neural horsepower
if you have any any other commitments on
your time so in some sense if you choose
the path of the dissident or the
heterodox or the crank you will find
that the your only hope and chance is to
have a really novel idea about how this
game goes so that you have some time and
some breathing room for everyone else
and of course nobody is very optimistic
about that prospect because it's very
difficult to do work on one's own as
einstein did in the Patent Office in
fact we haven't seen the second version
of his story since his famous emergence
from the Patent Office however the fact
is is that the traditional community is
also stalled out so you have two horses
neither which seems to be capable of
finishing the race and the question at
this moment is should we be looking more
to the heterodox running the risk of
craziness and cranks or should we be
looking more to the traditional
community which seems to have gotten
itself in a cul-de-sac that we call
string theory M theory and supersymmetry
the jury is out but I think it's it's
become a much more interesting question
because traditionally we would have bet
on the experts but the experts have
taken more time researching this theory
than any any group I think has ever
taken to research a theory and the fact
they have been unable to find anything
in fact means that perhaps the odds have
changed in that race
[Music]